a mis espaldas es uno de los dos puentes
que dan acceso a esta isla de afanacitca
en el río ingués uno de los afluyentes
principales sino el principal del Río
nieper en esta zona cerca a gerson y
como toda esta región sufrió las
consecuencias de la destrucción de la
presa de Nueva hopka el pasado 6 de
junio todos estos puentes tanto a este
como el otro quedaron sumergidos en el
agua y aquí lo que tuvieron que hacer
los militares fue poner un puente
militar para evacuar a quienes querían
salir de esta Isla especialmente quienes
habitan A los alrededores del río como
esta familia que habita en esta casa y
que solamente ha vuelto a habitarla
Desde hace dos días aunque la encontró
totalmente por lo menos en su interior
totalmente destruida y especialmente los
muebles y todo los equipamientos de la
casa dañados y esto es interesante que
esta es una isla que ha tenido una gran
relación como todas estas Riberas del
Río con la invasión rusa después del 22
de febrero del año pasado estuvo en
control de las fuerzas rusas aquí dicen
que estuvieron especialmente las fuerzas
chechenas y esta familia por ejemplo
tuvo que evacuarse arriesgando su vida
En aquel momento con una bandera blanca
y estuvo ocho meses por fuera de su casa
volvieron en diciembre y ya empezaban
otra vez a rehacer su vida Cuando vuelve
a suceder esta inundación Ahora les toca
rehacer absolutamente todo nos mostraban
su cocina nos mostraban los cuartos nos
mostraban los baños y si bien han vuelto
a vivir aquí pues obviamente dicen que
tienen un gran trabajo por delante y
sobre todo no tienen las condiciones
económicas la mayoría de hombres aquí
trabajan por fuera de la isla en
construcción o algunos hoy en día son
militares como el padre de esta familia